and we don't have to go into it but I
think it was pretty important to you you
said a lot of stuff to say about
aging in in Hollywood they freeze us at
the age they feel we were our best like
we aren't allowed to grow past that and
that was very that that was very
profound and it and I wanted you to just
talk about that a little because I know
that it was important to
you yeah it's such an interesting so I
actually it was actually Taylor Swift
that said that um I'm I'm Swifty um wait
Taylor Swift said what I just said not
not that exactly but she was talking
about the idea that like people freeze
you like they they have this moment when
they fall in love with you right as a as
an artist or a creative or a celebrity
or whatever it is that you're seeing as
to people and they they pick this moment
and then that's who they want you to
always be um and there's something
really beautiful about that but there's
also something really not okay about
that in
that it it it's interesting I don't want
to say that aging is hard because aging
is a privilege it means you're here it
means you're still living it it means
your every line is because of a smile or
a laugh you had or in my case too many
crying scenes which have given me like
this like I'm just always crying on on
camera I no what but I earn those right
like every crying scene I earn those hey
guys I'm doing another live podcast
downtown LA at the Regent Theater and my
special guest for January 24th
is Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad Jessica
Jones this is going to be a soldout
event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so excited so it's
beautiful but Aging in Hollywood is
really hard it's really hard because you
can't do anything right you know I had
this thing like a few weeks ago and this
is what made me text you about it I had
uh I was getting my hair done and I had
not a stitch of makeup on so I threw on
a filter and it was just a filter that
like at the time looked nice in the
light at the salon I really gave it no
thought and I put it on and the picture
ended up somewhere and a bunch of people
were like Jif for of hu is
unrecognizable and then another place
was like she's unrecognizable and so
she's gone to filter because she doesn't
want us to know how how bad she actually
looks now in her 40s God and I was like
this is crazy right so then I did a
bunch of like over-the-top like crazy
filters on my Instagram and I was like
all natural no filter like trying to
make fun of it and then they came after
me for that and they were like well now
she's just defending herself and like
why is she defend and I realized I was
like I can do I can do no I can do right
and why are you focusing so much on
these who have nothing better
to do than to put you down because
because to pretend that we don't is a
lie I know I know you're right we're
human and yes they're known as haters
and they're known as people who like
you're just supposed to turn your
comments off and you're supposed to but
it's human nature to be like what do
people think about me